Taylor Swift is ready to speak now about
overcoming an eating disorder I feel
really good about not feeling muzzled
anymore
it was by undoing hurtful headlines
where someone said that I looked
pregnant photos where Taylor might have
worn something that made her lower
stomach look not flat
those were the quote triggers that would
cause her to stop eating when you have
20 paparazzi outside your apartment it
kind of makes you take ownership of how
you look and you know it's gonna be
documented and discussed and debated
Taylor opens up about the eating
disorder in her new documentary Miss
Americana which debuted last night at
Sundance
she tells variety she even had a
strategy for dealing with questions
about food or her size she says that
when she was a size double zero if
anyone expressed concern she'd say what
are you talking about of course I eat I
just love food so much like Japanese
food like room service my choice
indulgence is like a great burger
I need doughnuts I need doughnuts on the
bird I know I don't do that but I
seriously I'd love doughnuts like all
hours of the day doughnuts the now happy
size six star says I did exercise a lot
but I wasn't eating I also just had a
treadmill put on my tour bus I have to
deconstruct an entire belief system toss
it out and reject it and there's another
Taylor twist today
he has learned she will not be attending
the Grammys this weekend even though
Taylor's up for a trio of awards she was
snubbed in two big categories
[Music]